[Musique]
et ce crise et y un cri de colère ni
aguilar par rapport à tous les
dérèglements qui lie actuellement ce
soit au niveau social au niveau sociétal
ou au niveau environnemental et cris de
colère et les cris d'alarmé on l'a vu ça
sert pas à grand chose et au contraire
l'opposition en énergétique appelle
l'opposition et donc appel de la
résistance par contre ce que j'ai appris
dans les arts martiaux chinois c'est que
la plus grande des forces et la douceur
donc le cri que j'aimerais pousser ce
soir c'est un cri d'amour et plus
spécifiquement ce cri d'amour par
rapport à l'art et par rapport au
financement là je suis artiste et
entrepreneuse j'accompagne les
dirigeants et les artisans leur prise de
parole en public
et puis je crée je produis des séries
sur les thématiques écologiques
est ce que j'ai vu plusieurs fois au
moment de faire financer mes oeuvres
d'art c'est des points de blocage et ses
points de blocage il ne concerne pas que
moi mais qui concerne aussi des tas
d'autres projets qui sont très
intéressants qui sont passionnants mais
juste par des oppositions ne peuvent pas
se produire
et ces oppositions il ya 15 ans quand
j'ai créé mon premier one man show on
m'a dit mais alors ton one man show
c'est pour du théâtre privé ou pour du
théâtre public
comment ça pour du théâtre privé ou du
alors pour faire une grosse caricature
le théâtre privé c'est le théâtre qui a
besoin de public et du coup
l'intelligentia aurait tendance à dire
que ils ont des pièces un peu plus
racoleuses et puis le théâtre public
c'est du théâtre entièrement financé par
le service public donc finalement ça
peut être plus élitiste et ils ont moins
besoin d'aller chercher le public
et puis plus tard quand j'ai créé ma
série en animations en fait je suis allé
voir une chaîne une chaîne made in an
mais votre projet il peut pas à la fois
être artistique et rentable comment ça
un projet peut pas être à la fois
artistique et rentable et donc en tient
un problème moi généralement je vais
m'inspirer de la nature et du coup je me
suis dit qu'est ce qui dans la nature
est à la fois privée est à la fois
public et j'ai pensé à l'arbre est ce
que le paradoxe de l'arbre c'est l'arbre
il n'oppose pas le privé et le public
mais au contraire en fait plus le privé
se développe plus le public se
développent et comment fonctionne un
arbre à un arbre il va se nourrir
il va aller chercher dans les racines il
va aller se nourrir de tous les
nutriments
il va agrandir et il va faire pousser
ses branches il va faire des feuilles
il va faire des fruits il va permettre
aux oiseaux de se poser délicatement il
va nous apporter de la fraîcheur de
l'humidité et ensuite ses feuilles vont
tomber ses fruits vont tomber et savard
nourrir le sol est ce que fait l'artiste
c'est quelque chose d'assez similaire à
ça l'artiste il va chercher dans ses
profondeurs
l'artiste il va chercher dans ses
émotions au plus profond de lui même
ce qui compte pour lui ce qu'il ressent
ce qu'il perçoit skill-capped du monde
et puis il va le transformer pour le
rendre intelligibles par les autres et
puis cette transformation il va l'offrir
au public et le public va recevoir cette
information et en recevant cette
information va pouvoir se reconnecter à
ses propres émotions
donc c'est un travail extrêmement
essentiel et on comprend du coup
pourquoi on a besoin que l'artiste crée
un art qu'ils soient vivants est un art
qui soit vibrant un arbre un arbre et
cet art vivant et cet art vibrant à
chaque fois qu'on demande à un artiste
pour se faire financer d'aller rentrer
dans les cases
parce qu'on fait c'est qu'on est en
train de le déraciné et ça pose vraiment
des problèmes parce que si c'est plus
vivant
c'est plus vibrants
et cet art vivant et cet art vibrant on
en a tous besoin
ce décalage en fait que je vois et que
j'ai entendu quand on m'a dit non mais
ça peut pas être à la fois artistique et
rentable c'est un peu la même chose que
si j'avais entendu armés ça peut pas
être bien enracinée et donner des fruits
c'est la même chose alors qu'on sait que
le principe c'est que plus est enracinée
et plus ça peut donner des fruits et
cette séparation je l' ai vu également
quand je j'aide des dirigeants à prendre
la parole en public vers la plupart du
temps les dirigeants quand ils ont des
difficultés à prendre la parole en
public c'est des problèmes de l'ordre de
l'intimé en fait de l'or de l'émotionnel
mais pendant des années en fait on a
demandé aux dirigeants de penser qu'avec
ça qu'avec leur tête et du cou de se
couper totalement de leur partie
émotionnelle et de leur ressenti on sait
évidemment que si on se préoccupe pas
beaucoup de ses émotions par les
émotions des autres on va pas s'en
préoccuper non plus on a demandé de
penser que en chiffres et du coup pensé
que en chiffres ça serait voir un arbre
comme un nombre de planches donc se dire
ma cet arbre c'est en planches cet arbre
c'est en plancher cet arbre c'est en
planche
sauf qu'on a vu un arbre c'est beaucoup
plus que des planches donc ce décalage
qu'on voit aujourd'hui dans les écoles
de commerce dans les écoles de
management qui commence tout juste à
faire en fait des formations à
l'intelligence émotionnelle mais c'est
vraiment un début et surtout il n'y a
pas encore la question du sens de
pourquoi qu'est ce qu'on est en train de
cultiver
quelle culture et cette question-là
culturel est essentiel parce que ce
qu'on voit fleurir actuellement c'est
beaucoup de crises et beaucoup de burn
out et ses crises et c'est burn out
elles sont visibles par nous tous
actuellement on le voit dans les grèves
on le voit dans les manifestations les
gens n'en peuvent plus
cette séparation est là pas de sens
est ce que j'aimerais en fait qu'on
qu'on voit aujourd'hui quand j'ai trouvé
cette image de lumbres ça m'a d'autant
plus marqué que l'arbre en fait qu'ils
étaient face à mes fenêtres 24 heures ou
48 heures après avoir trouvé cette image
à 8 heures du matin il ya un charmant
petit bruit de moteur qui est arrivé est
l'arbre devant les fenêtres et passé
deux ans de ça à ça et inutile de vous
dire que forcément les oiseaux ne s'y
passe d'un psy pose plus et comme les
oiseaux ne s'y pose plus je trouve que
c'est assez révélateur de ce qui se
passe dans notre société actuelle
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe si on décide
de tout privatiser
si on décide de tout privatiser c'est
plus un arbre
c'est une racine et qu'est-ce qui se
passe
si on décide de tout rendre public
ben c'est plus long qu un arbre à ce
moment là c'est un bois mort donc on a
bien conscience que chaque individu
on est à la fois un individu dans un
collectif
on l'est à la fois une intimité et une
intimité dans un espace public
on est les deux en fait et les deux ne
se sépare pas et les deux ne se dissocie
pas là il a une fonction de nous nourrir
de nous nourrir intellectuellement et de
nous nourrir
émotionnellement et cette fonction elle
est extrêmement importante parce que ce
qu'on attend de l'art effectivement
c'est qu'ils nourrissent visuellement
qui nous nourrissent émotionnellement
qui nous nourrissent intimant qu'ils
soient riches de tous ces nutriments et
qu'il soit populaire quand aujourd'hui
les plateformes américaines audiovisuel
arrive on dit les envahisseurs mais non
c'est pas du tout les envahisseurs c'est
juste qu'ils apportent des nutriments
que nous ne produisons plus donc c'est
normal qu'ils aient ce succès ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est qu'on va dire
aux artistes
effectivement de rentrer dans les cases
et puis on va même aller jusqu'à leur
dire comment ils doivent écrire ça ça
pose vraiment un problème
est ce que si on leur dit comment ils
doivent écrire ça veut dire que on
n'utilise pas leur valeur intrinsèque
qui est cette capacité à pouvoir capter
le monde à pouvoir percevoir le monde
bien avant tout le monde
bien avant les datas et donc cette
capacité à pouvoir sentir le monde à
pouvoir percevoir le monde
finalement quand on coupe de ça notre
société au cours toute notre société de
l'émotionnel et je trouve ça vraiment
dommage
ce que j'aimerais c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on ne brille plus ni les artistes ni les
dirigeants parce qu'en fait les deux
ondées rôle extrêmement important
en fait les brides et ça serait comme
demander à un arbre ne surtout pas
pousser au niveau de ses racines ne
surtout pas pousser au niveau de ses
branches alors culturellement en france
on a l'habitude de faire ça ne pas
laisser les a repoussés au niveau de ses
branches
on appelle ça le jardin à la française
je pense que ça vous parle tous mais en
fait on a besoin de cette vie on a
besoin de cette liberté
on a besoin de cette audace est ce que
la nature nous apprend c'est que la
nature ne sépare pas la nature ne dit
pas c'est l'un ou l'autre la nature dit
c'est l'un et l'autre est un artiste
peut être pragmatique et un dirigeant
peut être créatif
donc mon cri d'amour c'est une
invitation
une invitation à nous reconnecter à
notre nature profonde et confiante et
cette invitation
elle est également dans le fait de la
prochaine fois que vous allez voir un
arbre de prendre le temps de vous
connecter à toutes les parties de vous
même de prendre le temps d'observer cet
arbre qui est à la fois invisible est
visible qui est à la fois intime et
public et que vous preniez ce temps et
je crois que c'est comme ça qu'on peut
avoir une économie et une écologie qui
soit à la fois globale et saine
merci
[Musique]